bienvenue en 2020 une année au cours de
laquelle de nombreux projets portés par
le conseil départemental vont se
concrétiser
je pense au collège de vouneuil sous
biard pour lequel nous allons poser la
première pierre mais aussi la reina
l'historial les casernes de pompiers qui
vont se concrétiser ici à poitiers même
au cours du premier semestre 2020 c'est
une année pour laquelle nous allons voir
aussi que nous sommes allés sur de
nombreux projets plus loin encore tout
ce que nous avions annoncé
je pense au nouveau plan tourisme avec
un plan de développement du du
futuroscope qui va permettre la création
de nouvelles attractions de nouveaux
emplois je pense aussi à l'aéroport
indispensable à de nombreuses
entreprises indispensables pour le
développement du touriste et pour lequel
son emploi étaient en jeu et nous avons
vraiment tenu ici à maintenir la
sauvegarde de l'aéroport ils n'ont pas
oublié également pour cette année de
voter un nouveau schéma unique des
solidarités parce que notre
responsabilité est d'accompagner celles
et ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
est ce ce que nous faisons avec nos
politiques en faveur des personnes âgées
des personnes handicapées est
essentiellement aussi autour de la
protection de l'enfance c'est notre
responsabilité
comme il était notre responsabilité bien
évidemment d'avoir des actions pour la
sauvegarde notre planète nous y sommes
tous attachés et nous avons voté un plan
ambitieux qui va se décliner tout au
long de cette année 2020 un plan sève
avec un plan arbres et de nouvelles
plantations et puis aussi avec un
développement d'un certain nombre d'
espaces naturels sensibles
vous voyez nos actions sont très
diverses sont multiples mais nous avons
également tenu à évidemment à voir aussi
nos actions en matière de développement
culturel et puis en faveur du sport
c'est fondamental c'est fédérateur
ce sont de belles valeurs de respect
évidemment de solidarité et c'est pour
ça que nous allons en parallèle au label
terre de jeu
à voir au cours deux des quatre
prochaines années un nouveau plan pour
développer le sport sur nos territoires
voilà notre ambition est permanente elle
va continuer à se développer tout au
long de cette année
mais en ce jour bien particulier se
tenait évidemment à vous adresser tous
mes voeux pour chacune et chacun d'entre
vous bonnes années 2020